when it comes to the terrorist threat
first and foremost it is a national
responsibility to take steps to prevent
terrorist attacks against populations
however within NATO we can strengthen
the exchange of information and
intelligence one issue or particular
importance right now is the threat
stemming from what we call foreign
fighters national citizens who travel to
Syria or Iraq and maybe join the Islamic
is the so-called Islamic state and then
afterwards returned to our countries and
and they constitute a continuous
terrorist threat and NATO member states
have taken steps to reinforce measures
against that threat first and foremost
let me stress that we are faced with a
terrorist organization that has carried
out horrific acts it calls itself
Islamic the Islamic state but it's
neither Islamic nor estate it is a pure
terrorist organization and I consider it
an obligation for the whole of the
international community to fight that
terrible terrorist organization as far
as NATO is concerned there hasn't been
any request for a NATO involvement in
the fight against the Islamic state but
individual NATO member states have been
asked to assist the Iraqi government and
I appreciate very much that the United
States has taken the lead
of an international coalition to fight
ISIL I think determined military action
is needed I also have to say in full
honesty that air operations alone won't
do the work we will need ground troops
the question is only which ground troops
and I think countries in the region
should engage in that respect as far as
NATO is concerned we have decided at the
recent NATO summit that NATO stands
ready to assist the Iraqi government in
building a better defense capability if
they show request until 2011 NATO had
actually a training mission in Iraq and
personally I think it would be a good
idea to resume that training mission to
increase the capability of the Iraqi
security forces but obviously the
requirement would be an Iraqi request